so first up Emma is one of Jane Austen's
most adapted books out there so when you
first read the script what was it about
that screenplay that said to you this is
worth another telling the thing that
made it all worthwhile was meeting
autumn dewild the director she was
deeply impressive and she spoke about it
in a way that it was really unexpected
I'd never heard anybody speak about
anything and including Jane Austen quite
as she did and she made me laugh and she
spoke about bringing up baby the Cary
Grant and Katharine Hepburn movie as a
kind of tonal reference and anybody who
speaks of bringing up baby is okay with
me because I think I think you know if
you don't like bringing up baby I don't
want to have dinner with you I mean I
don't when you're moving in next door or
anything like that it's just because
it's one of the great movies of all time
but and I was encouraged by that
because I like the idea of it because
Jane Austen is a satirist and she's a
you know a comic writer and it's not
always emphasized and so I thought and I
knew I was in the presence of somebody
who was really really smart so with all
of your experience what do you do when
you have a project across your path with
a first-time feature director what do
you first look for the second you meet
the person well first of all you have
the script and obviously you go about
you know buy the script you just like
like if you were meeting anybody you
just want somebody who's straightforward
and I and I'd prefer someone who speaks
to me in plain language rather than you
know psychiatric terms do you know no
mean well they they talk about primary
energy and secondary at secondary energy
I don't got nothing against it it's just
that it doesn't help me know what to do
I don't know what to do so I like
someone who says you know practical
stuff and isn't frightened of saying it
plain what do you do when you're already
committed to a project and you're honest
set and just an actor's director style
isn't kind of gelling with what you just
said how do you adapt yourself to fit
what they do
well it doesn't been very fortunate and
it hasn't very often happened to me what
I do is I tend to go into myself and I
do every I do a kind of radical thing I
think it's something it's probably
something that people do in certain
kinds of martial arts where you go into
yourself any role with the
and you just kind of you I I have this I
have this promise to myself that I will
attempt to interpret whatever they ask
it's never going to be what they
actually ask for because it has to go
through me and you and therefore it's an
inexact science and you can never do
that so it's so I don't feel
proprietorial about it particularly if
they're offensive then we have a problem
because I do think I do insist on
endless courtesy anything else is
amateurism and I don't like going to
amateur ville ever because I you know
it's a professional situation and I like
to stay there
endless courtesy is something we should
apply to every little piece of life well
yeah that's exactly it that's radical
this Punk yeah it's it's hardcore
so I was watching another interview that
you had done and you said something
along the lines of experience is
overrated when it comes to acting
specifically so if with a resume like
yours if you're not gaining
self-confidence through your wonderful
experience what do you find yourself
leaning on to give you that kind of
self-confidence that you're now in it
well it's very difficult because you
know no matter how I'm not necessarily
sustained by precedent you know so I I
used to stand at the back door every
time I got a job the night before I
started the job the first day is always
the worst you know I'd go through all
the credits in my head and think you
know where they ask me back that's
always big news they asked you know they
wanted to do it twice you know even I
can't turn that into a conspiracy you
know that seemed to work out okay you
know I go through the things to try and
get me you know through the thing I
don't necessarily do that so much now
although you know first days on jobs
they're always you know I do find it
difficult to sustain any kind of
confidence but what I do to combat a
fear of work is work
I mean to be cute about it as a kind of
bumper sticker but if I if I work really
hard and if I immerse myself in the
pardon in the role and in the script and
I know my and then I know my lines
absolutely backwards so that I can give
the appearance of spontaneity and give
the appearance that I've never said
these lines before and they've only just
occurred to me that's the gig that's
basically my job it's not rocket science
but it's not nothing either and I and I
find it endlessly fascinating it sounds
like the healthy balance right there but
that spontaneity how is it bringing that
kind of mentality to a movie like this
where the the pacing and the tone just
feels so precise to me is that something
you can naturally feel working on set or
do you have autumn saying you know give
me a different intonation on this line
at any given moment I don't think she
ever gave me an intonation she may have
done and I don't I I welcome into
nations if anybody has a better idea of
how to say I'm up for that you know I
might dispute it but mostly I'll go with
it you know I it with archaic language
and the costume and all of that you know
the UH the unfamiliarity of everything
it is it is a bit of a challenge you
know and you it takes a couple of days
to get into that I think that with as
with not that I've ever done much
Shakespeare I've done a little bit of
Shakespeare I think with that you have
to work doubly hard on the language in
order to get it to roll you know really
roll and you have to mine it for
naturalism you have to find a natural
way of delivering it in some way
it's obviously heightened in style
therefore it's never going to be I mean
there is no such thing as naturalism
obviously you know but uh but you know
it has so therefore you have to find a
tone in which to deliver those kind of
words I can barely get through my
questions naturally so I can't even
begin to wrap my head around what you
guys do we play a game on collider
called would you rather all the time so
I want to pose a question to you that
kind of leans into what you have to do
in the role because he his reaction
shots are very very important but also
the delivery of certain dialogue is key
also and there's a lot of a very
dialogue heavy scenes in this movie so
would you rather have your character
just do reaction shots for an entire
scene or have to deliver a dialogue
heavy that monologue for a scene well we
I think that's a very very good question
and it would depend on the scene I was a
blah blah blah but in the end the answer
would be I'd rather have a load of
dialogue just because it gives me
something to do I mean you can do other
stuff too but I do like I enjoy the
challenge of trying to deliver dialogue
you know particularly if you've got it's
like in the theater if you've got a long
speech you better mix it up a touch you
better make it attractive because you
know people will you know they'll fall
asleep on you so and at that and I
enjoy that kind of challenge I got one
that has nothing to do with this movie
whatsoever would you rather have to fake
sneeze or fake vomit in the scene I'd
rather have to fake sneeze okay all
right I don't want to say first you can
do a convincing fake sneeze yeah I think
I can I can definitely do a fake vomit
yeah Emily Blunt Emily Blunt used to
whenever I work with element Emily Blunt
a while a couple of times and whenever
anybody it was ever suggested that I had
any kind of romantic contact with any
other human being
she would always fake vomit as if it was
the most disgusting thing she'd ever
heard and she would do that thing of
making a mouth fill with vomit you know
where they don't actually be sick they
just will do that thing which was always
very tell me I don't know where that
came from but I hope I cross paths with
her now